The need to get from A to B is something we’re
all familiar with.
In the US, most people spend about an hour
traveling to and from work – not to mention
all the other sorts of traveling we do.
But despite all the work engineers put into making
those journeys go smoothly, it seems like things go
wrong more often than they should.
Maybe you’ve been delayed at the airport,
encountered signaling issues on the subway,
or got caught in a traffic jam.
While the weather often plays a role, one of the biggest reasons that transportation systems run into issues is that they have to deal with another persistent, difficult, unavoidable element: us.
If you want to design a good transportation
system, you have to understand the people
who are going to use it.
[Theme Music]
Transportation engineering is one of the largest
disciplines of civil engineering.
Every highway, railroad, shipping lane, and
airline route relies on transportation engineers
to guide the way.
Suppose you were tasked with setting up a
subway system for a city.
You’ll need to plan, design and construct
every last element before it can function.
What’s more, transportation systems are,
almost by definition, heavily connected – every
piece needs to support all the others.
It’s no use having state-of-the-art trains
on brand new tracks if the stations aren’t
built where people need them.
And once a system is up and running, you’ll
need to constantly monitor how it copes with
demand.
That will help you make decisions like how
to improve access to stations and how often
to run trains.
The same kind of thinking applies to plane routes
and shipping systems, although roads and highways
have some extra considerations.
The physical aspects of engineering we’ve
learned about so far play a big part of the
design work.
You need to build components out of the right
materials and put in the right safety features.
For example, you’ll want to build the subway’s
tracks with enough mechanical strength to avoid
buckling because of an overloaded train.
And the key element in transportation engineering
is people.
We’re a core part of the system.
Unlike other disciplines we’ve looked at, this kind
of engineering isn’t about processing inanimate
materials into something that we use or consume.
It’s about moving people in a way that’s
safe, convenient, and comfortable.
That means considering social requirements
in addition to physical ones.
For instance, how do you decide where to build
tracks, and which locations they should connect?
Ideally, you’d build enough infrastructure
to support every journey that anyone would
want to take.
But, like everything else in engineering,
cost is one of the biggest constraints you
have to work with.
Since you probably have a fixed budget for
setting up the system, you need to prioritize
what what gets built and where.
And to do that, you have to understand what
kinds of journeys are going to be made.
So with a subway, some people will want
to visit their friends or go shopping, while
others are just trying to get to work.
The layout needs to support those different
needs, while making enough from the passenger
fares to keep the system up and running.
So the social and economic goals of your city
have a big role in the design of the network!
In general, transportation engineering is often about
taking a bunch of different priorities and combining
them in the best – but rarely perfect – way.
And that applies on every scale!
Your new subway system, for example, might have a
point where two lines merge into one, taking passengers
from different starting locations to the same stop.
But if two trains approach at the same time,
how do they both pass through?
Obviously, no one wants a collision.
So your job as an engineer is to design a
system where the odds of that happening are
as small as possible.
Since we’re dealing with heavy objects travelling
at high velocities, the routes need to be designed to
allow changes to those velocities well in advance.
While a car traveling at highway speeds can
safely stop over a distance of a hundred meters
by applying the brakes,
a passenger train travelling at the same rate
needs over a kilometer before it comes to a halt.
That’s also why air traffic controllers have to
constantly monitor and communicate with planes
that are flying at similar altitudes.
Because a passenger plane can’t be maneuvered quickly, the flight paths need to be designed to ensure that flights from different locations overlap as little as possible.
Schedules need to keep them out of each other’s
way, while also avoiding turbulent weather.
But to avoid collisions at your train junction,
you’ll need signaling.
To give each train enough notice when it
has to stop, you’ll need regular signals at
intervals along the track.
Those intervals are also known as block sections.
Signals give useful information about what’s happening
on the tracks several sections ahead, like whether there’s
another train or if it’s safe to travel at full speed.
To allow enough time for the train to respond
and stop, block sections tend to be no shorter
than the necessary stopping distance.
Older signaling systems rely on a set of lights
above or beside the tracks that a driver can
interpret and respond to.
For your brand-new subway, you’d probably build in wireless signaling capabilities to relay information straight to the train cabin, to the driver or an automated system.
If two trains are approaching the same junction, signaling would tell one of them to slow down several block sections ahead while allowing the other to pass through.
And that choice can be made in a few different
ways.
If one train is slightly closer to the junction,
it might make sense to give it priority while
the other is told to wait.
But if the other train was delayed earlier on its route,
you might want the signals to give it priority, even if it’s
farther away, to help get it back on schedule.
Or, if you want to get as many people to their destinations as quickly as possible, you might let the train likeliest to be carrying more passengers through first.
The details will depend on the particulars
of the routes and the needs of your system.
Railway signaling involves managing a whole
network!
Modern approaches are also sophisticated enough
that safety mechanisms, like electronic sensors,
will automatically stop a train if the signals
indicate danger ahead.
When they’re working, the combination of
signals and tracks give trains a big advantage:
they go where they’re supposed to, when
they’re supposed to.
But many people mainly get around with vehicles
like cars, trucks and motorbikes.
In Britain, for example, about two thirds
of all journeys are taken in an automobile.
With every driver free to move independently,
roads lose much of the predictability that
railroads enjoy.
Potential collisions aren’t confined to
known junctions – they could happen every
time someone changes lanes!
And even if accidents don’t happen, all
that switching back and forth causes something
we’re probably all familiar with: traffic jams.
To understand why, it actually helps to think
back to fluid dynamics.
In general, a highway system is well-designed
if as many cars as possible are flowing through
the system as fast as safely possible.
So, on a given stretch of highway, you can think of
the “efficiency” of the system as the flow rate of cars.
The flow will be the product of the density
of cars passing through and their average speed –
much like the flow of water through a pipe.
Except the driving force here isn’t water
pressure.
Instead, it’s every driver’s individual
desire to get to where they’re going.
If there’s only a few vehicles on the road,
it’s not a problem.
The cars don’t have to fight for lane space
or slow down because of other drivers.
Everyone cruises along at roughly the speed
limit.
That’s what engineers call “normal flow”.
In normal flow, you can increase the total
flow rate just by adding additional cars.
In other words, more people move through the
system and the highway is doing its job.
Add too many cars, though, and the problems
start.
In normal flow, the extra cars don’t affect
the average speed of each vehicle.
But once the density of cars reaches what’s
called a critical point, the lack of space between
cars starts causing restrictions.
Everyone drives a little slower to accommodate
the other cars around them.
Add even more cars, and you start getting
stoppages.
When one car slows down or stops, the others
behind it have to slow down too, and so on.
This brings down the average speed of all
the cars on the road.
Even though there are more cars, the flow rate
actually decreases past the critical point because
their average speed has dropped so low.
That’s what engineers call forced flow.
Everyone’s desire to get ahead actually
makes the problem worse.
Each car trying to desperately squeeze through
every opening makes it harder for the jam to ease
up and for the cars to flow steadily again.
There might be other routes drivers can use
to get to their location, but in general,
every driver wants to take the shortest route,
which seems pretty sensible on the face of it.
But when everyone uses the same route, forced
flow occurs.
You might think that building another road
or adding more lanes would improve things.
In practice, though, most people still take
the route they think will be fastest, which
only makes things worse!
So highway engineers tackle problems like
this in sometimes unusual-sounding ways.
One solution comes from German mathematician
Dietrich Braess.
Instead of adding more roads, you can actually
improve traffic flow by taking them away.
That might seem counterintuitive, which is
why it’s called Braess’ Paradox.
After all, how can the flow be improved by
removing a highway?
Braess’ Paradox works because when the
seemingly-fastest route is taken away, drivers end
up using several alternative routes instead.
Even if those alternate routes are longer,
they only take a fraction of the cars each.
That keeps speeds higher and the flow rate
closer to normal.
On average, people will even get to where
they’re going faster on the longer route.
Of course, that’s just one solution that
only works for some highways.
In general, you need to accurately model
the flow of traffic and develop sophisticated
ways to keep it flowing.
Many of the the same principles used for signaling
on railroads carry over to programming traffic lights
and even the design of roads themselves.
The way roads merge and connect has a big
impact on how drivers act and the eventual
flow patterns.
In the future, if fleets of driverless cars take to the road,
it could require whole new principles of highway design
– much like automatic train networks did for railways.
But even if humans won’t be behind the wheel,
transportation engineers will still be there,
ensuring that those journeys are designed
to be safe, fast, and convenient.
In this episode we looked at transportation
engineering.
We saw how transport systems are designed
from the outset, what decisions need to be made,
and how to operate them with the help of signaling.
We learned how systems like highways are built
around the behaviors of their users,
how considering traffic flow lets us assess
a highway’s efficiency, and ideas transportation
engineers can use to improve it.
Next time we’ll explore how engineers create
communication systems like the one you’re
using right now.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
Wanna keep learning?
Check out Origin of Everything, which explores
the history behind stuff in our everyday life,
from the words we use, the pop culture we
love, the technology that get us through the
day, or the identities we give ourselves.
Subscribe at the link in the description.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.